ich bin hier am strand von rimini
normalerweise liegen hier die liegen
hier leben menschen die kabinen einen
mann an der jetzt komplett leer und ist
auch nicht ganz absehbar waren wir
deutschen und wieder wieder herankommen
aber ich werde ich werde jetzt gabriele
das ist der legendärste bademeister von
von rimini ich wecken jetzt fragen wann
wann die die strände hier wieder
aufwachen in vintage ingrid macht sich
total ische christsein übertreffe die
wird ihre rohmaterial also am 25 mai
dürfen italiener oder die einwohner von
hier wieder zum strand für die deutsche
optimisten sagen hat mitte juni aber
steht eigentlich in den sternen wann
ausländer wieder an den strand kommt für
mich war das wie ein erlebnis wie ein
bisschen wie eine mond eine mondlandung
dass sich jemand fuß auf diesen strand
setzen konnte es fliegen sogar
helikopter die darüber wachen dass keine
menschen die immer dass keine menschen
hier am strand sind es ehrlich gesagt
auch so dass der bürgermeister von von
von rimini mich gestern gesprochen aber
andreas so ein junger dynamischer
bürgermeister der sehr beliebt ist ist
eigentlich ganz froh dass dieses image
von rimini als neutronen grill der
vergangenheit angehörten er möchte im
grunde diese corona krise nutzen um
diesen ort anders ein andere form von
tourismus zu haben mehr kulturtourismus
ökologischer tourismus aber so leute wie
gabriele sehen dass man sich vollkommen
an dass er freut sich wenn dieser strand
die ja voll ist und deswegen werde ich
ihnen geht fragen gabriele was ist deine
nachricht an die deutschen eu kommissar
joe pesci dies freue mich auf euch liebe
deutsch als ihr seht es
wir werden hier sehen ist